was gilt nun im kampf gegen das virus
seit der regierungsrolle rückwärts zum
gründonnerstag laboriert das land das
saarland will nach ostern ein fast
normales leben durch schnelltests
möglich machen
bremen zieht dagegen die notbremse
deutschland ein patchwork pandemie
projekt dabei steigen die zahlen der
neuinfektionen weiter stark an und das
robert koch institut warnt eindringlich
zur vorsicht und das vertrauen der
bürger in die politik schwindet massiv
hoffnung wird allein durch den impfstoff
genährt wenn die eu genügend zur
verfügung hat im zickzackkurs durch die
pandemie wie steht deutschland da unser
thema in der phönix konnte
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen aus berlin ich darf
meine gäste vorstellen hier im studio
ist miriam hollstein chefreporterin
politik für die funke mediengruppe davor
war sie chefreporterin bild am sonntag
und welt herzlich willkommen und rolf
dieter krause ist bei uns langjähriger
leiter des europa studios der ard in
brüssel
zugeschaltet ist uns aus tübingen der
modellstadt für corona management boris
palmer von bündnis 90/die grünen er ist
oberbürgermeister der stadt schönen
guten abend nach tübingen und ich grüße
wolfgang bosbach von der cdu bis juli
2015 war er mitglied des bundestages und
zuletzt vorsitzender des
innenausschusses
herr bosbach jetzt schauen wir auf diese
woche und haben gesehen dass es eben
eine große verunsicherung gibt statt
mehr vertrauen was läuft da ihrer
meinung nach gerade schief es gibt viele
baustellen an denen dringend gearbeitet
werden muss die wichtigste die dringende
ist sicherlich das thema impfen aber ich
finde es ist ein zeichen auch von
persönlicher größe wenn die kanzlerin
die verantwortung alleine auf ihre
schultern legt denn sie war ja nicht
alleine mit ihr waren 16
regierungschefinnen und regierungschefs
aus den bundesländern
mir persönlich ist es lieber dass jemand
ein irrtum eingesteht sich korrigiert
als dass jemand im irrtum bei hard unter
der überschrift hauptsache ich behalte
recht und wir sehen ja im
internationalen vergleich wiederum beim
thema impfquote dass wir im moment auf
platz 34 35 sind und das für so eine
große starke industrienationen die
eigentlich weltweit dafür bekannt ist
dass sie gut organisieren gut managen
kann
das ist enttäuschend und für mich ist es
auch nachvollziehbar dass die menschen
draußen im lande von der politik mehr
erwarten als das was wir in den letzten
monaten an guten politischen
entscheidungen anbieten konnten
diese bitte um verzeihung macht die denn
ja die fehler wett weil das war ja
wirklich auch in handwerklicher fehler
dass da was beschlossen wurde wohl nicht
klar war wie es eigentlich umzusetzen
ist
nein aber ich finde es war ein zeichen
von größe es geht um das thema impfen
mehr und schneller es geht um das thema
schutz wohnblock personen nur ein
einziges beispiel die über 80-jährige
machen acht prozent der bevölkerung aus
aber 40 prozent der schweren verläufe
mit tödlicher folge also an oder in
verbindung mit corona gestorben es geht
um eine test strategie und es geht um
die kontakt nachverfolgung um das
unterbrechen von infektionsketten dann
leistet unsere corona war jedenfalls
stand heute nicht das was sie leisten
könnte oder was sie leisten müsste nur
ein kleines beispiel mein letzter
hinweis war als stolzer besitzer dieser
app sie hatten zwei begegnungen mit
niedrigem risiko ja was mache ich jetzt
damit nicht wann nicht wo das ist doch
kein informationswert den wir eigentlich
brauchen richtung gefahrenquellen zu
erkennen und infektionsketten zu
durchbrechen daran gibt es eine menge
kritik für holstein das war eine
schwierige woche also die beschlüsse
werden dann zurückgenommen und jetzt
gibt es auf einmal ja die diese
information das saarland bildern bald
richtig öffnen mit tests andere sagen
das geht so nicht machen eine andere
strategie also jeder ministerpräsident
läuft jetzt irgendwie eine andere
richtung hat die kanzlerin auf gegeben
irgendwie nein aber ich glaube man merkt
auch ihr inzwischen an dass sie
erschöpft ist und so ein bisschen
zermürbt ist und vor allem merkt man ihr
an das ist einfach eine schwierige
situation ist in der man immer wieder
dinge ausprobieren muss und dann
teilweise eben auch damit scheitert
insbesondere mit zogen schnellschuss ich
glaube dass wir ein grundsätzlicheres
problem haben in deutschland nämlich
dass all das was bei uns ja eigentlich
so eine qualität war nämlich dass wir
gründlich waren dass sie alles besonders
gut vorbereitet haben dass wir uns immer
an den regeln orientiert haben dass das
in der pandemie eben nicht mehr
funktioniert sondern dass sie sich
eigentlich ins gegenteil verkehrt dass
wir unflexibel geworden sind dass wir um
mutlos geworden sind
dass wir nichts mehr ausprobieren und
mir ist dieser satz des baudirektors für
krisen programme malereien aus dem
letzten jahr aus märz aus dem märz schon
in erinnerung geblieben der gesagt hat
wenn man glaubt dass man immer richtig
liegen muss bevor er loslegt wird man in
dieser pandemie nicht gewinnen es kommt
jetzt nicht auf perfektion an es kommt
auch ein bisschen auf geschwindigkeit an
und deswegen finde ich tübingen so
bemerkenswert da läuft ja auch nicht
alles perfekt aber es wird zumindest
ausprobiert und ich glaube das ist jetzt
ganz wichtig ist eine gute überleitung
zu hören palma sie haben eben dieses
modellprojekt seit zehn tagen ist auch
ein richtiges modellprojekt zum
eröffnungs schritten mit teststationen
und dann können die menschen halt eben
wieder relativ viele dinge eben machen
die in anderen orten nicht möglich sind
heißt es ist dass die entscheidung für
mut und eben nicht die ja nicht alles
nachrichten nach den regeln machen
ja das ist entstanden was weiß ich seit
einiger zeit praktiziert weil die regeln
einfach nicht zur realität passen muss
auch mit einem beispiel wir haben seit
etwa acht wochen
diese neue generation der schnelltest
zur verfügung die man nur noch in die
nase stecken muss drei zentimeter tief
und dann nach 15 minuten ergebnis hat
deutschland hat sich mal wieder sechs
wochen zeit gelassen um das zuzulassen
und wir haben gesagt wir warten nicht
auf die erlaubnis zum nase bohren wir
haben diese tests in die schulen
gebracht und wir testen die schulen in
thüringen allein diese woche fast 10.000
tests in den thüringer schulen jetzt
regelmäßig zweimal die woche die
schülerinnen und schüler können das
selbst und zwar nur weil ich gesagt habe
ist mir egal
und das kommt man leider nicht voran und
es geht halt nicht mit bürokratischer
perfektion
unser versuch selbst dort passiert jetzt
nicht so sehr auf mode sondern ist
einfach ein experiment mit offenem
ausgang
es ist ziemlich klar wir haben
einerseits viel mehr kontakte als amazon
weil sie bei uns ins theater ins kino in
die außengastronomie und auch wenn alle
leben gehen können
auf der anderen seite aber haben wir
auch die höchste text dichte in
deutschland wir haben diese woche für
60.000 schnelltests bei einer
bevölkerung von 90.000 menschen
durchgeführt und jetzt musste das
experiment zeigen
das ist dominant welcher effekt wirkt
stärker die zusätzlichen kontakte oder
die test dichte ich kann ihnen zumindest
mal sagen nach 16 tagen öffnungen des
einzelhandels in tübingen nach der märz
haben wir aufgemacht müsste man
eigentlich erwarten wenn man lauterbachs
theorien folgt das alles immer schlimmer
wird das bei uns die zahlen explodieren
wir zumindest die normale vorhersage
tatsache ist wir hatten die ganze zeit
eine inzidenz von 130 und sind stand
heute zum ersten mal bei 33 angekommen
und resident ist stabil
während sie im bund sich in der gleichen
zeit fast verdoppelt hat und das scheint
mir schon ein guter hinweis darauf zu
sein dass dieser risiko tausch
funktioniert dass es möglich ist durch
das schnell testen mehr freiheit zu
gewähren und sogar trotzdem die inzidenz
niedrig zu halten
okay das ist eben das modellprojekt
tübingen herr krause wenn sie das hören
und auf der anderen seite auch noch mal
auf diese woche schauen wo halt eben die
so viel verunsicherung gekommen ist dann
haben wir jetzt auch noch ein eu-gipfel
gehabt weil es ja auch immer noch darum
geht auf die große hoffnung impfstoff
die dann eben auch nicht so funktioniert
was ist denn ihre bilanz damit von
dieser woche was das vertrauen der
bürger betrifft
ich glaube die politik hat im moment
auch nicht sehr viel vertrauen verdient
sie macht ja vieles falsch und ich teile
die meinung von einem bus noch überhaupt
nicht dass das jetzt große geste von der
kanzlerin war die hat in einen fehler
zugegeben und sich dafür entschuldigt um
druck aus dem kessel zu lassen
über die vielen anderen fehler die sie
begangen hat sagt sie gar nichts das
beginnt mit der impfstoff beschaffung da
war sie ist die gesagt hat das soll die
eu-kommission machen eine behörde die
damit null erfahrung hat kein nichts
davon weiß
gesundheit ist kein thema bei der eu
gefasst also hat kein kompetenter fields
an kompetenzen im doppelten sinn des
wortes die die eu hat weder das recht in
der gesundheitspolitik viel zu machen
noch hat sie die erfahrung also die
fähigkeit aber es zu machen das muss
frau merkel bewusst dabei hätten sie
denn einen nationalen alleingang der
bessere von 1 aber ersparen wir doch auf
einem völlig richtigen weg indem er sich
mit einigen ländern zusammen getan hat
und er hätten ja andere dazukommen
könnten
die idee in den ländern das können mit
der pharmaindustrie verhandelt hätten
das dann gemeinsam machen können das
muss doch nicht eine behörde machen dies
nicht kann
belgien ist ein land das hervorragende
erfahrung hat im in verhandlung mit der
pharmaindustrie da hätte man sagen
können und macht das für uns alle und
wir schließen uns halt an dass die heute
im bundestag da stellt sich die
kanzlerin und sagt keine stadt ist daran
gehindert so was zu machen wie tübingen
oder rostock dass die andere stadt die
die es auch hervorragend macht ja warum
sind eigentlich kein warum sind denn
keine ideen aus berlin gekommen was man
machen können was machen sie dann kann
man ja machen ohne das andere zu lassen
wichtig aber warum ist das wichtigste
was von der vom bund bisher kommt sind
methoden der pandemie bekämpfung mit
denen haben wir schon vor hunderten von
jahren die pest bekämpft jetzt kommt die
impfung dazu und die tests ja das ist
das gab es damals noch nicht aber
kontakt beschränkung etc
abstand halten ja das war auch gegen die
pest das private mit zu helfen haben wir
den sehr eigentlich genutzt im letzten
jahr als es wäre relative ruhe hatten wo
sind die ideen wie genau wir haben im
vorigen frühsommer leute gesagt wir
müssen die menschen in den altenheimen
besser schützen nichts ist passiert und
dann haben wir uns gewundert dass sind
manchen landkreisen wo es viele
altenpflegeheime gibt denn die instanzen
dann in den himmel schoss was haben sie
denn gedacht hat einmal als sie den satz
der kanzlerin gehört haben dass sie
gesagt es ist keine bürgermeister
verwehrt das zu tun was in tübingen und
rostock gemacht wird gerufen werden sie
angerufen von vielen anderen
bürgermeistern die fragen die machen sie
das ich möchte das auch machen
mittlerweile ja ich kann das auch gar
nicht mehr bewältigen muss den kollegen
leider sagen ich muss jetzt erstmal den
modellversuch zum erfolg führen bitte
informiert euch über die website aber
der satz der kanzlerin der hat mich sehr
verwundert ich habe nicht gehört aber
wenn er so gesagt wurde dann ist er halt
einfach unwahr denn das was wir hier
machen also zusätzliche öffnungen
anbieten unter der bedingung dass man
den schnelltest macht war bis vor einer
woche
einfach verboten die landes corona
verordnungen haben dass nirgendwo
erlaubt und es war keinen bürgermeister
möglich das zu tun im gegenteil ich habe
mit den kollegen aus rostock und dem
kollegen aus münster vor der letzten
vorletzten ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
ein appell an die große politik in
berlin und in der die landesregierungen
formulierten gesagt haben ihr könnt uns
in den kommunen vertrauen wir wissen was
wir mit unseren bürgerinnen und bürgern
auf die beine stellen können gibt uns
mehr freiheiten gibt es mehr
verantwortung die ist bei uns gut
aufgehoben und arbeitet nicht immer noch
mit vorschriften die uns vor setzt am
sonntagabend und am montag morgen wird
die stadtverwaltung geht dann schon
realisieren so liegt es jetzt nämlich
alle vier wochen dass wir am
sonntagabend die verordnung könnten die
wird dann umzusetzen also das herz da
kanzlerin ist falsch es ist jedem
bürgermeister verwehrt gewesen irgendwas
in der weise zu realisieren was wir in
tübingen und rostock machen und erst
seit einer woche ist es mit
sondergenehmigungen endlich erlaubt
worden deswegen wundert ist dass die
bundeskanzlerin so etwas gesagt haben so
hat sie heute im bundestag
herr bosbach was sagen sie dann wie wenn
man das jetzt sieht wie in tübingen das
gemacht weil dies in rostock gemacht
wird warum funktioniert das warum wird
das nicht so angelegt dass man sagt das
wäre wären so können was in ganz
deutschland umsetzen warum ist da so
eine ja also eine langsamkeit und ebenso
wenig flexibilität und zu wenig mut ja
letztendlich auch zunächst ist mir nicht
bekannt dass ist kommunale
öffnungsklausel gab in den verschiedenen
landes verordnungen denn das was in
großer runde beschlossen wird muss ja 16
mal in den bundesländern durch
entsprechende verordnungen in
rechtssprache gegossen werden mir ist
nicht bekannt dass man städten und
gemeinden oder kreisfreien städten oder
landkreisen die möglichkeit gegeben hat
in eigener verantwortung abzuweichen es
wäre gut wenn das jetzt rechtlich
geregelt würde damit die betroffenen
bürgermeister landräte nicht in einer
rechtlichen grauzone arbeiten
man hat sich sehr sehr lange auf die
inzidenz früher einmal auf den erwert
konzentriert und das thema lockdown
stand über allem
dabei ging es eigentlich von anfang an
um die frage der risikoreduzierung der
rechtzeitigen erkennung von infektion
und der unterbrechung von
infektionsketten und das war ja das was
auch viele verwundert hat ist einmal
richtig man hätte die sommerpause nutzen
müssen für einen intensiven schutz
variabler bevölkerungsgruppe nicht nur
aber insbesondere in alten wohn und
pflegeheimen und viele hatten sich doch
intelligente hygiene konzepte ausgedacht
auch in der praxis realisiert in der
gastronomie in hotels in theatern in
ganzen kulturbetrieb wir sprechen jetzt
nicht von großen pop und rock konzerten
wir sprechen nicht von vollen stadien
sondern wir sprechen von intelligenten
konzepten und kaum waren die auch in der
praxis erprobt kam der lock down und
mich wundert es schon diese
unterschiedliche betroffenheit dass die
nicht eine größere rolle spielt denn
diejenigen messe messebau kulturbetrieb
gastronomie hotel die jetzt nach monaten
mit dem rücken zur wand stehen die nicht
wissen wie es mit ihren und ihren
betrieben wirtschaftlich weitergeht die
könnte nicht diese ruhe und diese
gelassenheit aufbringen die diejenigen
haben die wissen dass sie kein
persönliches risiko haben die nicht um
ihren arbeitsplatz bangen und die ganz
sicher sein können dass ihr gehalt
pünktlich und in voller höhe kommen das
ist ein großer unterschied auch in der
wahrnehmung dessen was in den letzten
monaten geschehen ist trotzdem steigen
die zahlen dramatisch an frau holstein
ist dies ist die dritte welle ist da
man merkt die todeszahlen steigen nicht
so extrem wie noch im winter aber die
infektionen auch gerade bei kinder und
jugendlichen steigen an
also wie kriegt man das zusammen also
wie kann man einerseits flexibler seien
die konzepte die hygiene konzepte alters
mit benutzen aber andererseits ja doch
klar die warnung geben sollte man ja
nicht ignorieren also in welchem dilemma
ist da auch zum beispiel die kanzlerin
ich glaube schon dass es die lösung
dieser dreiklang ist den sie auch immer
wieder in den regierungserklärungen
nennt nämlich dass man schneller impfen
muss dass man
umfassend testen muss und was man ja
jetzt in jüngerer zeit öfter hört ist
das eben auf regionale konzepte gesetzt
werden muss ich finde ein problem ist
dass das ich mich bei der politik der
wirtin corona maßnahmen der regierung
oft an diesen spruch von mark twain
erinnert fühle dass wenn das einzige
werkzeug was man in der hand hat ein
hammer ist halt alles wie nagel aussieht
und das ist gefühl habt ihr schon
geschlagen seit monaten mit diesen
lockdown lockdown leid auch wenn er für
viele hart ist schlagen wir einfach die
ganze zeit drauf und es klappt mal ein
bisschen besser aber das ist natürlich
keine langfristige lösung und da fände
ich wäre es einfach wichtig tatsächlich
auch mal menschen zu fragen die für
ihren bereich konzepte entwickelt haben
so ist ja auch die loop entstanden und
dann zu versuchen es besser zu
integrieren und ein zweiter punkt den
ich ganz wichtig finde ist dass die
vorhandenen möglichkeiten nicht
vollständig ausgeschöpft werden also ein
eine sache die total bemerkenswert finde
ist dass seit januar bekannt ist dass
bei diesen bei montech ampullen 7 dosen
oft nicht immer aber oft bei drei
viertel ungefähr entnommen werden könnte
aber der hersteller übernimmt nur die
haftung für sechs- und deswegen sagen
die landesregierung ja dann können wir
nichts machen und das führt dazu dass am
abend also entweder die ärzte impfen
halt unter der hand wenn sie die siebte
rausgezogen bekommt es sind ja experten
die können es beurteilen ob das nur
siebter ergibt oder nicht oder sie
müssen halt abend für abend
lebensrettenden impfstoffs vernichten
und da verstehe ich nicht wir wissen das
seit januar warum wird es nicht ganz
schnell von der landesregierung dafür
gesorgt dass die haftungsfrage geklärt
ist dass es die regierung übernehmen und
es verkauft werden kann
der boss doch sie wollten dazu was sagen
ja weil wir diesen kampf ihren im
rheinisch bergischen kreis seit wochen
führen in aller kürze es gibt sogenannte
sehr hohe risiko an spritzen wo die
siebte dosis gewonnen werden kann
das ist dem rheinisch-bergischen kreis
vom land nordrhein-westfalen verboten
worden
das war ein wochenlanges gezerre nicht
etwa weil man die spritze nicht benutzen
dürfe sondern weil der leitende arzt
angeblich den dienstweg nicht
eingehalten
um sich das genehmigen zu lassen das
haben das hat ja kein mensch vorstand
dann haben die sendung maischberger in
der sendung maischberger hat armin
laschet gesagt einfach machen genau das
tut der kreis jetzt und das
landesgesundheitsministerium hat zu
protokoll gegeben dass das auf eigene
verantwortung des kreises geschieht und
sie werden viele hundert menschen in den
letzten wochen zusätzlich impfen können
und das sind ja die scheinbaren
kleinigkeiten mit großen auswirkungen
denn solche probleme dürfte es überall
im land geben nicht nur hier im
bergischen land 3 haas heiliges das ist
für mich unsere bürokratie und die macht
ihren striebel runter und niemand fängt
sie ein
das ist politik versagen par excellence
ich sag immer beispiel eigentlich weil
sie haben bei dem sie an und sie kennen
ja die anderen europäischen länder ist
das wirklich was man sagt das ist doch
überall dasselbe das ist wir sind was
bürokratie angeht noch ein bisschen
perfektionistischer in anderen ländern
macht man das was er gemacht hat ein
bisschen direkter in belgien zum
beispiel das kenne ich ganz gut in
italien
da sagt man am ende irgendwann die
bürokraten sollen stelle sein wir machen
einfach da da gibt es so was wie eine
bürgerliche anarchie aber ich sage ihnen
mal beispiel ich habe gefragt bin
rentner ich bin flexibel kann ich nicht
mit auf eine warteliste setzen kann um
abends wenn der impfstoff noch übrig ist
angerufen zu werden und dann dein geld
schnell hin und hole mir das geht nicht
ich wäre in 20 minuten in dem im zentrum
wo ich das machen könnte ich habe weiß
von einer zahnärztin ihren brandenburg
die hat sich bereit erklärt in ihrer
praxis ein testrennen zentrum zu
errichten
die wird mit bürokratischen
anforderungen überhäuft das kann nicht
das das ist nicht so glauben die muss
zum beispiel nach 30 jahren praxis noch
mal nachweisen dass sie als zahnärztin
zugelassen ist sowas lassen sich
bürokraten in unserem land einfallen und
das machen sie machen ihren strom rund
dann ist wäre auf dass das haben wir
nicht nur in diesem gesundheits bei das
haben wir in der wirtschaft wir haben
das an so vielen stellen
wo bürokrat nur öffentlicher dienst
einfach sein strehmel runter macht weil
er in der tat wie herr bosbach gesagt
hat nicht davon betroffen ist und das
wäre eine dringende aufgabe in dieser
verbots gesellschaft wo immer um eine
ist sagt dienstweg dass dies nicht du
das nicht so da gibt es menschen die ein
paar immer die sagen dann ich mache das
trotzdem herr palmer was ist denn ihre
erfahrung risikobereite ja sie sind
risikobereit also welche gefahren laufen
oder gibts dann laufen sie dann
bestimmte gefahren dass er das ihnen
dass jemand verwehrt was sagt ihr
ministerpräsident dazu oder würden sie
sagen das sollten eigentlich einfach
alle machen man muss sich eben einfach
trauen aber sind die gefahren also es
ist ziemlich einfach die gefahr ist dass
nachher eine schuldige gesucht wird und
es ist auch der hauptgrund warum in
deutschland die risikoaversion so
ausgeprägt ist ja wenn mal was schief
geht dann wird bei uns nicht gesagt na
ja das war nun sucht der war auch
irgendwie ganz gut gedacht aber hat
jetzt halt nicht geklappt sondern wird
nach einem schuldigen gefragt und dann
ist man vielleicht seinen job los und in
dieser angst kultur sagt zumal jeder
behördenleiter sagt jeder mitarbeiter
ich mache nur was von den vorschriften
zu 100 prozent gedeckt ist uns bin ich
dran und sich da auszuscheren muss man
sich trauen ich mache das weil ich
irgendwie geografisch so geprägt bin
mach' mein vater ist für seine
überzeugung ins gefängnis gegangen ich
sage ihnen geht's darum halte ich aus
wenn ich mal etwas gesagt habe was nicht
allen gefällt und ich bin auch ein
ziemlich schwäbischer dickschädel das
heißt wenn ich der meinung bin dass die
sich ausgedacht haben am grünen tisch
ist falsch da mach ich es einfach nicht
ich mache keine nun ziehen dazu dass ich
mich nicht zwingen und dann ziehe ich
die dinge durch so bin ich das hat mir
viel ärger eingebracht aber ich glaub
der pandemie ist es geradezu zwingend
wenn sie darauf warten bis alle
vorschriften erfüllt sind halt viele
leute gestorben dann war das
vorschriftsmäßig aber es ist damit
niemand geholt und man muss meiner
meinung nach in einer pandemie vor der
lage sein muss schneller sein als es ist
wer wusste wann was die vorschriften
liegen lassen und immer einigermaßen
klassik wo es lang geht dann muss man
stark
herr lauterbach hat aber trotzdem bei
ihnen das würde nicht funktionieren was
sagen sie ihm denn er sagt auch der weg
von tübingen kann ich
ich habe mir dann würde war schon viele
streit diskussionen gehabt er hatte auch
schon viele ganz falsche sachen
behauptet ja dann habe ich wie er den
wellenbrechern lockdown ende oktober als
die neueste erfindung der wissenschaft
gepriesen hat wir ein bisschen alle das
war vollkommen wirkungslos also er wird
zu unrecht als deko sie recht habe in
dieser pandemien dargestellt werde er
hat 50 prozent der aussagen waren halt
richtig 50 prozent waren falsch und wenn
er falsch lag sagt da ja das liegt daran
dass ja auf mich gehört habe deswegen
ist nicht so schlimm gekommen also was
sage ich wirklich gesagt hat oder was
sie müssen den unterschied als
rheinländer zwischen dem kreis tübingen
und der stadt tübingen noch analysieren
der kreis tübingen hat in der tat eine
stark ansteigende inzidenz wie ganz
deutschland
das hat aber mit der stadt tübingen
nichts zu tun wir hatten keinen anstieg
der inzidenz und das ist in unserer
nachbargemeinden den schulen und kitas
eine große zahl von neuen fällen gegeben
hat wie leider fast überall jetzt im
land mit einer neuen kritischen mutation
hat er nun wirklich nichts mit unserer
modellversuch zu tun also herr
lauterbach hat die zahlen nicht wirklich
angeschaut die falschen zahlen zitiert
und auch aus dem falschen schluss
gezogen
bisher ist es genau umgekehrt nämlich
soll ich wie ich gesagt habe wir fischen
so viele infizierte einer von tausend
test ist positiv so viele infizierte
raus die gar nicht wissen dass sie das
virus weitergeben würden dass wir damit
die pandemie bisher in tübingen unter
kontrolle halten können
also geht es so bleibt das wird man in
zwei wochen sehen dann haben wir damit
gezeigt dass es auch in anderen weg gibt
mit dem virus klarzukommen frau holstein
wenn man das hört wie sind funktioniert
in rostock funktioniert wenn zum einen
die kanzlerin sagt andere sollen das
dann auch so machen
warum gibt es da nicht mehr klarheit
auch in dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dass man
sagt ja in diese richtung wollen wir
marschieren und dass man weil jetzt ist
es ja vor allen dingen verunsicherung
übrig geblieben wie kriegt man das
wieder hin dass die bürger dann wieder
vertrauen fassen und auch wissen wer sie
eigentlich durch diese pandemie führt
also ich glaube der der große frust bei
den bürgern ist auch dadurch entstanden
dass sie den eindruck haben dass sie
sich seit über einem jahr viele nicht
alle aber viele massiv einschränken und
versuchen ihren teil dazu beizutragen
dass die pandemie
zurückgedrängt wird und dass es eben von
regierungsseite aus dieser auftrag nicht
erfüllt wird und es fängt bei so klein
ist oder nicht kleinigkeiten aber das
fängt mal so ich muss sagen fast
banalitäten an dass uns gesagt wurde
wenn die schulen wieder geöffnet sind
gibt es eine umfassende tests strategie
und wenn man sich jetzt umwelt dann ist
an ganz vielen schulen wird es einfach
nicht umgesetzt
und dann kommen zu einem
ministerpräsidenten konferenz in die die
leute die wo die leute abends ins bett
gehen und hören vielleicht gibts oster
lockerungen über die ostertage und dann
waren sie morgens auf und dann ist auf
einmal der oster lockdown wie so ein
faules ei im ostern ist da und ich
glaube diese form der verwirrenden
kommunikation ist ein großes problem
aber wir machen sie da hauptsächlich für
verantwortlich das war schon die runde
der ministerpräsidenten plus die
kanzlerin insofern fand sie ist schon
richtig dass sie da auch die schuld auf
sich genommen hat ich fand es aber auch
wichtig dass die ministerpräsidenten
dann nicht versucht haben sich dann weg
zu drücken weil es ja alle gemeinsam
entschieden haben
ich glaube wichtig wäre dass man solche
vorschläge schon etwas besser
vorbereitet und sein leben auf sehr viel
also dass man auch mit dem
gesellschaftlichen gruppen bespricht
dies betrifft ob das funktionieren kann
vorher und ich die kirchen dann
plötzlich sagen also hier gottesdienste
wussten ja gar nichts davon oder der
einzelhandel gründonnerstag unser
umsatzstärkster tag was soll das jetzt
und dass man dann eben wenn man es dann
beschließt auch sehr sehr klar und auch
sehr konsequent kommuniziert der dosb
hat da die politik oder diejenigen die
ministerpräsident nun auch die kanzlerin
haben die da wirklich so ein bisschen
die erdung verloren dass sie eben
wirklich nicht danach daran denken was
das zum beispiel für die kirchen
bedeutet was das für den einzelhandel
bedeutet wie kann so etwas passieren
eigentlich das kann dann passieren wenn
solche runde nicht gründlich vorbereitet
werden ist darf sichern die man für die
vorstellung machen da sitzen 17
persönlichkeit mit einem weißen blatt
papier und fangen jetzt an nachzudenken
und zu schreiben sondern so etwas wird
ja vorbereitet entweder im kanzleramt wo
die länder koordiniert werden oder durch
die staatskanzleien der länder
und da gibt es sitzungen die dauernd 10
12 stunden das kennt herr krause
sicherlich aus brüssel noch besser als
die anderen in dieser runde
und da kannst du ja nicht mit leeren
händen vor das publikum treten dann muss
man ja ein ergebnis haben beim letzten
mal war es ja in der tat so dass so
viele fragen offen blieben die hätte man
erst also praktisch und rechtliche die
hätte man erst klären müssen bevor man
eine entscheidung trifft
da hätten wahrscheinlich die zuständigen
ministerien sofort gesagt leute wie ihr
euch das vorstellt so geht das nicht
schon mal gar nicht in der kürze der
zeit und vielleicht wäre es gut wenn
nicht nur virologen epidemiologen bei
der vorbereitung beteiligt werden
sondern auch praktika sachverständige
aus der wirtschaft verfassungsrechtler
oberbürgermeister aus tübingen menschen
die hinterher wie diesen rechtlichen
regelungen im alltag umgehend müsse und
eins ist klar ein oberbürgermeister ein
landrat ist vielmehr an den menschen und
an ihrer lebenswirklichkeit als es die
bundeskanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten können weil ihr ein
anderes amt haben eine andere aufgabe
eine andere verantwortung deswegen bin
ich ja dafür dass man mehr auf die
praktiker hört denn herr palmer hat ja
auch nicht gesagt augen zu und durch
lauterbach tritt zur seite wir öffnen
sondern er hat ja diese öffnungs
konzeption eingebettet in einen schutz
und in ein test konzept so kann es dann
funktionieren aber ich fürchte er hat
mit der diagnose recht die akte muss
sauber sein
es wird nicht wenige geben die lehnen
sich zurück und sagen ich mache exakt
das was wir rechtlich vorgeschrieben
wird denn wenn irgendwann etwas passiert
will ich mir nicht sagen lassen können
dass ich gegen recht und gesetz
verstoßen habe
ich kann so etwas verstehen aber es
braucht eben auch mutige menschen die
sagen wir versuchen es eben mal und wenn
wir sehen es funktioniert nicht so wie
wir uns das vorgestellt haben dann sind
wir auch bereit korrekturen vorzunehmen
das ist mir lieber dann sind ja wirklich
durch diese per verzeihung der kanzlerin
und diesen fehler jetzt echt an seinem
tiefpunkt gekommen was diese pandemie
politik betrifft und das vertrauen ist
eben wirklich enorm gelitten herr krause
wie krieg
das zurück gibt es wurde auch gesagt wir
sollen andere formate sagte herr söder
also dann nicht um dich nicht erst
nachmittags anfangen dann die ganze
nacht tragen sondern vielleicht auch
schon morgens ihr boss tatort sie kennen
das ja auch von von brüssel ist das eine
stärke der kanzlerin gewesen in der
nachtsitzung und dann so lange fit zu
bleiben bis die anderen ist nicht mehr
schaffen also machen diese formate noch
sinn
darüber kann man in der tat nachdenken
ist es richtig dass zum beispiel die
chefs sich immer um diese sachen kümmern
war schon der finanzkrise so die
fachleute
die finanzminister waren dann weitgehend
außen vor und mit ihren riesen apparaten
und mit entsprechender expertise und die
regierungschefs die lackierten zum teil
sehr fröhlich vor sich hin
so und jetzt will ich jetzt machen wir
es in der gesundheitspolitik wieder
ich weiß nicht wie gut die
landesgesundheitsminister sind aber dass
die von den sachen meistens mehr wissen
als ihre ministerpräsident ja auch dass
man natürlich nicht nur an gesundheit
denken muss sondern auch an wirtschaft
und auch noch an andere dinge
das kann man ja dann immer noch zusammen
führen ich glaube dass diese methodik
weil sie zeitlich ja kein gutes ergebnis
wir haben einen massiven
vertrauensverlust und ich und ich und
ich kann dem auch nicht gut
widersprechen
ich finde aber gleichzeitig haben wir
doch glück ich erlebe jedenfalls in den
verschiedenen umgebungen in denen ich
mich bewegt dass viele leute sagen okay
ob die politik kannst du dich nicht
verlassen
verlasst jetzt verlasse ich mich auf
mich selbst und ich trag halt meine
maske ich mache die kontakt vermeidung
ich flieg auch nicht da mallorca sondern
sie verstehen nicht dass das das die
inkonsistenz bei vielen geschichten dass
man dass man nicht in die ferienwohnung
oder in das ferienhaus nach brandenburg
oder nach schwaben oder sonstwie würden
mehr eigene verantwortung mehr zutrauen
dass ich glaube dass sehr viele bürger
diese eigenverantwortung wahrnehmen weil
sie das gefühl haben und sagt auf das
was uns gesagt wird von da oben können
wir uns nicht mehr richten sind sieht
der fehler ist dabei dass das so nach
dem motto viel hilft viel dann viele für
noch strengere regelungen
sind die können im einzelfall richtig
sein aber manchmal sind sie gar nicht
nötig aber ich sehe das doch sehr viele
leute sich sehr verantwortungsbewusst
verhalten
eltern von kindern die manchmal
verzweifelt sind was ihnen in den
schulen zugemutet wird etc so und und
das ist im moment das was bleibt und ich
habe den eindruck dass dieses
verantwortungsbewusstsein einzelner
menschen gar nicht so schlecht ist und
unser land das unterscheidet uns
übrigens von manchem europäischen land
frau halten wie würden sie es
einschätzen wäre mehr eigenverantwortung
etwas wo die politik wozu die politik
ermutigen kann oder ist es gerade der
wunsch dass da jemand da oben steht und
wirklich klar sagt wo es langgeht
also ich würde auch sagen dass das eine
entwicklung ist die wir gerade besonders
stark erleben nämlich je schwächer die
führung ist um auch umso mehr sind auch
die bürger und bürgerinnen gefragt und
das nehmen sie ja in der tat auch
größtenteils war
ich finde es war eine große geste dass
sich angela merkel entschuldung doro
dass sie um verzeihung gebeten hat aber
ich finde zu seiner entschuldigung
gehört und in einer beziehung und
letztendlich sind die bürger mit dieser
regierung in eine beziehung gehört ja
auch dazu dass der der um verzeihung
bitte zeigt was er dann besser machen
will und erst recht ein angela merkel
noch die richtige um dieses land aus
dieser krise zu führen
da würde ich meine gegenfrage stellen
wer soll es denn sonst machen momentan
wir können ja mal alle durchdeklinieren
den vizekanzler oder
die fdp die lieber gar nicht regiert als
schlecht regiert oder armin laschet
erstmals ein ja ja weil die anderen ist
auch nicht können es hat trotzdem die
frage nochmal berechtigte ob sie ist gut
machen wird ist man es gibt viel zu
kritisieren aber ich kann nur sagen es
wäre der nackte wahnsinn in einer
situation in der wir uns wahrscheinlich
auf den höhepunkt dieser pandemie zu
bewegen oder also mitten in die dritte
welle hinein ist die oberste
krisenmanager managerin auszutauschen
und zu glauben dass das dann besser
werden würde ab ganz ganz abgesehen
davon dass ich auch glaube es gibt es
gebe niemanden in die in dieser
situation mit ausnahme vielleicht von
friedrich merz der jetzt gerade lust
hätte dieses amt zu übernehmen
bundesligavereine alles falsch weil sie
in der krise ihre träger entlassen
herr bosbach sollte man jetzt den
trainerinnen entlassen also wie was
würden sie sagen wie gefährlich ist dass
auch diese frage seit der
vertrauensfrage diese ganze diskussion
die jetzt aufgekommen ist also wenn wir
jetzt noch eine vehemente
regierungskrise hätten ist angela merkel
ihrer meinung nach noch die richtige das
land jetzt aus der krise zu führen
ja wir haben eine vertrauenskrise
viele sind enttäuscht und ich füge hinzu
ich kann diese enttäuschung auch
verstehen und bin nicht bereit wenn
fehler gemacht worden sind drumherum zu
reden oder zu sagen das musst du jetzt
auch noch verteidigen weil du in der cdu
ist in der politik geht es im kern um
vertrauen und wenn du das vertrauen
verlierst ist wie im privatleben geht
ganz schnell oder brauchst du jahre um
dieses vertrauen wieder zurückzugewinnen
was jetzt noch fehlt dass wir ein
politisches scharmützel beginnen um die
nachfolge von angela merkel ja liebe
leute wie stellt ihr euch das leben
das wird kein austausch geben können
die spd kann überhaupt kein interesse
daran haben dass aus dem amt heraus
jemand aus der union als kanzlerkandidat
2021 im september antritt dann wird er
vorgezogene neuwahlen geben
das können wir uns nicht erlauben wenn
millionen mit dem rücken zur wand stehen
wir alle darauf hoffen dass es jetzt mit
dem impfen aber mal langsam fahrt
aufnimmt
dass wir eine überzeugende test
strategie nicht nur auf dem papier haben
sondern auch in der praxis dass wir die
die wir besonders schützen müssen auch
besonders schützen können und dann fängt
die politik noch an und für
parteipolitische spielchen auf oder
stellt personalfragen in den vordergrund
das alles können wir jetzt nicht
gebrauchen jetzt geht es nur um eine
einzige frage wie können wir die fehler
die wir in der vergangenheit gemacht
haben korrigieren und wie können wir
dafür sorgen dass wir die pandemie
besser bewältigen als wir das in den
letzten monaten getan haben das ist die
einzige frage um die es jetzt im moment
geht und nicht um partei und nicht um
persönlichkeit und nicht um wer will was
hier werden die frage ist ja trotzdem
wie inwieweit sich parteipolitiker
versuchen zu profilieren auch
ministerpräsidentin
herr palmer wies schauen sie von
tübingen aus auf diese runde wo von wem
würden sie sich da ja vielleicht eine
andere performance wünschen wer ist für
sie jemand wo sie sagen dass da er läuft
es gut ich sage mir der frage dass ich
mich gar nicht ich gucke mir dann am
nächsten tag an was wir beschlossen
haben und haltungsnoten wer da jetzt
welchen beitrag geleistet hat das ist
eher was für die politischen
interpretations künstler in ihrem beruf
da halte ich mich raus
ok und wie wichtig ist es dass das also
das impfen welche rolle spielt das bei
ihnen in ihrer strategie da habe ich
keinen einfluss drauf so billig wie nie
an herrn bosbach anknüpfen darf ich bin
schon der meinung wir könnten auch jetzt
immer auch eine bessere strategie finden
was ist denn unser problem in der
strategie das ist nicht dass die
kanzlerin den fehler gemacht hat mit dem
ersten april dem gründonnerstag sondern
dass wir ein ganzes jahr lang immer an
der gleichen falschen die prothese
festgehalten haben nämlich wir müssen
alle menschlichen kontakte vermeiden
aber völlig falsch
99 prozent der menschen sind ja nicht
infiziert wir müssten einen nur die
kontakten mit infizierten vermeiden und
das ist das ganze übel dass wir das
menschliche leben einschränken im 99
prozent ohne jeden grund und die
strategie könnten wir vielleicht ist es
sogar ein wendepunkt ist die kanzlerin
da jetzt sich entschuldigen musste dass
das endlich auch
und ja differenzierte lösungen finden
und diese konzerte lösung heißt auch ein
risiko eingehen und sich damit abfinden
dass man nicht immer alle erwischt mit
der schnellsten strategie erwischen sie
nicht alle infizierten aber hinreichend
viele und das reicht dann einfach mal
aus deswegen muss ich nicht mehr alle
kontakte unterbinden modell tübingen mit
der impfstrategie können sie auch besser
vorgehen als wir es getan hat wird jetzt
endlich korrigiert indem man nur die
erstimpfung gibt wie die briten das
machen und die 2te bevor irgendwann mal
später weil dann hat man schon den
schutz vor todesfall und schwerer
krankheit nicht sinnvoll aber den
weitgehenden muss man halt ein risiko
eingehen man könnte auch beim impfstoff
dafür sorgen dass wir in deutschland
viel schneller an impfstoff kommen wenn
wir das amerikanische prinzip der
notfall zulassung wählen also wenn wir
eine zulassung dann machen wenn der
impfstoff mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit
mehr nützt als schadet da muss man halt
den leuten freistellen ob sie den
impfstoff auch nämlich ganz konkret an
den typischen entwickelten impfstoff von
kubik die ganze nährstoffe basieren auf
der erfindung eines tübinger
wissenschaftler ist die ganze
technologie kommt aus thüringen in
thüringen sind millionen dosen
produziert sie dürfen nicht geimpft
werden warum weil wir jetzt noch eine
zulassungsstudie machen wo genau die
gleiche technologie eingesetzt wird wie
bei und tech und moderner wahrscheinlich
eine bessere wir warten jetzt erst mal
ab bis endlich irgendeinen bürokrat
gesagt hat die tabelle fasst wenn die
zulassung in europa die leuchter
ernsthaft so ab dass die beiden tech
moniert haben dass eine tabelle im
querformat im hochformat abgedruckt war
das musste dann verbessert werden damit
endlich nicht zu dass um geben kann
solange wir solche zuwächse haben
brauchen also nicht wundern dass wir
beim impfen nicht vorankommen also
notfall zulassung der impfstoffe bei
denen man ziemlich sicher sagen kann die
funktionieren und dann halt freiwillige
nutzung dieser impfstoffe und das letzte
ist endlich weg mit diesem datenschutz
fetisch wir könnten in vier wochen dem
funktionieren der tracing er kommt apple
und google wissen sowieso wo ich bin die
daten habe ich den immer weil ich mein
and wiederfinden möchte wenn es verloren
geht dieser standort ist immer bei apple
bekannt und ich weiß gar nicht was sie
mit den daten machen aber ich will mein
handy wieder sind wir nichts verlierer
himmel arsch und zwirn ich sag das mal
ganz deutlich auch dem gesundheitsamt
weil die information über lassen können
wo ich mich aufgehalten habe wenn der
infektionsgefahr gedroht hat und immer
das einmal geregelt hätte in vier wochen
wird es machbar ist
praktisch dann verlieren wir auch die
kontrolle über die infektionsketten
sondern haben sie dann tatsächlich im
griff das könnte man alles machen könnte
man alles nach regen ist dringend nötig
wenig nötig da mal dran zu trend zu
begeben aber trotzdem gibt es genug
menschen die das nicht wollen und die
dann auch bremsen
kraus ich würde mal gerne bei dem
gedanken wollen sie weiter in block 3
soll noch mal bei und die konsequenz
beim thema impfen bleiben und impfstoffe
noch mal auf die uhr schauen
oder wollen sie widersprechen der box
war
ich wollte nicht widersprechen aber ich
habe manchmal das gefühl bei diesen
fragen auch herr palmer will ja nicht
den datenschutz schleifen sondern wir
müssen prioritäten gesetzt werden ich
habe manchmal das gefühl wir haben vor
sorgenfalten der datenschützer mehr
furcht als von den sorgenfalten von
intensivmediziner aber die
intensivmediziner haben andererseits
diese beschichtung gelobt nämlich dass
es den härteren lockt und das erlaubt
dann verlängert wird weil sie sagen
diese zahlen steigen so hoch und man
muss weiter in diesem lokal an es geht
jetzt nicht und es geht darum ob wir
eine app haben die ihren zweck wirklich
erfüllen kann nämlich infektionsketten
zu durchbrechen infektions cluster zu
erkennen und dafür muss ich doch als
nutzer zumindest wissen wann und wo
hatte ich denn einlass ist dagegen aber
ich merke das ist ein risiko ist nur
zweite frage also das hört sich alles
wunderbar an und da kommt immer das
beispiel mit südkorea aber ich nun mal
der hinweis dass in südkorea sogar die
kreditkarten bewegung nachvollzogen
wurden das war dann sehr effektiv aber
herr bosbach sie waren ja lange genug in
der aktiven politik um zu wissen wie
viel dicker bretter man hätte bohren
müssen um so was hier in deutschland
umsetzen zu können da kann man jetzt
nicht sagen okay wir geben jetzt den
datenschutz mal eben so auf und das ist
eine notwendigkeit oder auch dieses mal
kann er den zug man auch dem zustimmen
man kann doch selber sagen dass ich
sagte wir haben bloß sind bestimmte
kultur hier und mit der und das betrifft
auch das thema notfall zulassung wenn es
dann irgendwie tote gegeben hätte dann
wäre hier die hölle los gewesen
insofern glaube ich man muss halt auch
damit arbeiten was von der mehrheit der
bevölkerung daran knabbert das ist sehr
willig
der noch installieren das datenschutz
die ausrede ist für alles mögliche um
dinge zu verhindern
es geht doch oft gar nicht mehr um den
schutz von daten eher palma doch völlig
recht wo ich bin wissen andere längst
weil ich mein handy auch wiederfinden
will und und und wenn wir vor der frage
stehen schützen wir leben oder schützen
wir unsere daten dann zuzugeben maßen in
der pandemie muss man doch auch dinge
mal neu bewerten können und und dann
weil zum beispiel bei einer
funktionierenden app dann wirklich da
ein hilfsmittel nehmen das wirklich
helfen könnte wenn wir alles unterlassen
was uns helfen kann und wenn wir und
unterlassungen jedweder art einerseits
machen
bürokratische vorschriften antrag tat
dann bleibt am ende nur noch der lock
down und der entzug von freiheitsrechten
etc und der stillstand von von weiten
teilen der wirtschaft und der bankrott
von gastronom die not von künstlern etc
etc
das muss doch nicht sein wir hoffen alle
auf diesen impfstoff und hoffen dass wir
das dann unseren leben wieder normal
leben ja und da wäre noch mal die frage
an den europa kenne also was wohl sagen
sie ist es kann das weiter funktionieren
hätte wäre es doch wäre es eben sinnvoll
gewesen wir hätten die notfall zu lassen
habe und würden dann nicht warten auf
die europäische und wie ist die wie
würden sie jetzt sagen die im moment die
europäische union damit umgeht
ja wir haben wir heute ein gipfel gehabt
mich und ich meine dass es am anfang
nicht gut gelaufen ist das hat ja jeder
gesehen ist doch ein bisschen
überraschen also ich habe der kanzlerin
jetzt nur zugehört nach nach dem ende
des gipfels
aber das was sie da gesagt hat lief
eigentlich darauf hinaus weiter so also
es gibt weder eine strengere
exportpolitik sondern wir liefern eine
andere wir bleiben offen
wir haben auch bei uns eigentlich wir
verteilen noch ein bisschen damit so
länder wie österreich die jetzt ja
meinen dass sie nicht genug impfstoff
haben obwohl sie wegen zu wenig bestellt
haben damit sie dann jetzt also in einem
akt der solidarität ein bisschen besser
dran sind aber an an sich habe ich heute
nach diese nach der in der
pressekonferenz der kanzlerin und nicht
wahrnehmen können dass da irgendetwas
passiert
und da was würden sie sich den wünschen
was wäre uns richtig was und damit wir
sind hier in europa mehr impfstoff hat
lebt die pandemie legt grundfehler auch
auf in unserem land aber auch in der eu
was ich seit langem beklagen dass die eu
nicht wehrhaft ist dass das das drückt
sich dann eben darin aus dass so ein
unternehmen wie astrazeneca nein mit der
eu einfach ein bisschen spielen zu
können
und das machen die daten lägen über ihre
produktionsmengen offensichtlich dann
bindet man mal plötzlich wieder paar
zigtausend wo in italien im lager und
und und sie halten sich nicht an
verträge etc so und warum machen sie das
weil sie es können weil sie den eindruck
haben die eu beißt nie und die eu bei
ist ja auch nicht sie beißt nicht in der
aussenpolitik sie hat heute auch
gegenüber der türkei nicht gebissen
obwohl die sich da im östlichen
mittelmeer aufführt wirklich wie ein
level und das sind dinge die haben ganz
viel mit deutscher europapolitik zu tun
unsere kanzlerin verhindert seit jahren
dass die eu wirft wird und das ist das
was man hier auch mit sich ich meine
jetzt kann man nur eins man muss den
impfstoff produzieren das ist im gang
dass die produktionskapazitäten werden
aufgebaut nach allem was ich höre werden
wir in einigen monaten sehr viel
impfstoff haben dann werden die
hersteller in einen wettbewerb das zeug
verkaufen können hoffentlich wird dann
die nächste mutation auch noch vom
impfstoff erfasst wenn noch weiß nämlich
keiner wie lange die impfung hält
und möglicherweise wird das sein wie mit
der krippe im punkt das wird einmal im
jahr das ding brauchen wir das könnte
seiner dann wäre es schon wenn wir alle
haben genug genug geld für alle genau
genau und ganz sicherlich wird das nicht
die letzte sendung zum thema kroner
management gewesen sein ich bedanke mich
ganz herzlich bei herrn bosbach bei hand
alba vor holstein und herr krause und
ich wünsche ihnen einfach nur weiter
gute gesundheit und ihnen liebe
zuschauer natürlich auch das war die
phoenix runde am donnerstag nächste
woche nächste woche ist der osterpause
sind wir gar nicht da ich wollte jetzt
sagen und ein kollege ist dann da aber
dann ist erstmal osterpause jetzt geht's
weiter bei phoenix der tag des tanzes
[Musik]